Evet
Hepinize selamlar sevgiler ve Bence de
dünlere sizlerle beraber aynısı oldu
bulmayı çok isterdim Evet İçinde
bulunduğumuz pandemi şartları gereği
sizlere Ancak bu kamerayı aracılığı için
kurabiliyorum
biraz sizlere kendimden bahsetmek
istiyorum 1981 emirdağ'da olmuyor
ailem emirdağ'dan Eskişehir'i göç ettiği
için bütün eğitim hayatında iskelet
almadım ilkokul ortaokul ve liseyi
Eskişehir'de bitirdim devamında
bilgisayar ve elektronik karşı olan
ilgimden dolayı da elektrik mühendisliği
Bölümü'nü
kazandım eski Türk mühendisliği
bölümünden 2005 yılında mezun oldu
devamında ise ay tesettürlü ve yazılım
üzerine
kariyer geliştirdim video Eskişehir'de
çalıştıktan sonra 14 yüzyılda bu
çalışmaktayım ve başuzman araştırmacı
olarak görev yapmaktayım 90'ların da
ortopedik engelli bulunuyor sağ ve sol
Ayaklarında protezler var bu yüzden
sayesinde günlük hayatta sorun yaşamadan
da
işlerimi hallediyorum
protezlere tanışmam ilk kez yedi
yaşındayken oldu Tabii ki protezleri
kabullenme ve ve kullanma süreci biraz
zorlu bir süreçtir bu süreçte ailenin
bana vermiş olduğu destek de beni motive
etmeleri sayesinde
yürümeyi ve kendi kendime işlerimi
yapabilmeyi
başardım
hem başlarda çok zorluyordu
Ankara'ya gidip geliyoruz işte Ankara'da
o zamanlar protezi yapılıyordu Sabahları
erken kalkıp su artık görürse bu kat
ettikten sonra Protez lerimiz için
doktorlarla buluşup
testlerini yapıp daha sonra hürmetine ne
yapıyorduk bu başta çok zor gelse de ama
okula gitmem için
profesyonel olması gerekiyordu okul
içerisinde gerek yürüyüşün evin
içerisindeki gülüşüm için çok önem arz
ediyordu bu protezlere alıştım
alıştıktan sonra ilkokul ve ortaokulun
başlarına kadar
okul içerisinde içerisinde ya çok
sokakta gezemiyorum bu şekilde projemin
kullanıyorum Babamla açtı konuştuk dedim
ya ben de hani o gün içerisinde ve
içerisinde
gelirken işte Sen ne olsun işte bu
şekilde geliyorum kendi kendime gitmek
istiyorum demiştim o da sağ olsun işte O
zamanlar tabii elektrikli scooterlar yok
Bana
motiften üç tekerlekli
hale getirdi ve onunla beraber
okula git ben de başladım
tek başına bir YouTube'u biraz özgürlük
kalktı Özgüven kalktı
muhabbetle hem okula gitmiyorum hem de
ya Fırsat buldukça Eskişehir geziyordum
Eskişehir'i o zamana kadar Google'ın
hepsi yok Ama eskilerin Bugün size
oluşturmuştu diyebilirim gezmeye ve
keşfetmeye karşılayacağım hala devam
ediyor bugüne kadar birçok şehir gezdim
yurtdışına çıktım ve Türkiye'deki bazı
dağlara çıktım
dua fotoğrafıyla da ilgileniyorum
başlarda
diğerleri vergileme kadar çektiği
fotoğraf bunu bayağı ilerledim Doğa
fotoğrafı çekmekten çok hoşlanıyorum
fotoğrafı çekmek için de et gibi gezmek
ve vakit doğada vazgeçmek gerekiyor bir
ortopedik Engelli olarak da doğada vakit
geçirirken gezerken Öncelikle bazı
şeylere çok dikkat etmemiz gerekiyor
seviyorum yazmadan bahsediyorum eve daha
uzun söyle bir Ne yapacaksınız e
protezlerin izinde Herhangi bir sorun
olmaması gerekiyor Beni bir haftalık bir
geziye gittiğimizde ya probleminizin de
bir sorun yaşarsanız oralarda Elif sizin
için Savcı saatler geçen Öncelikle yeni
protezin kemerleri olsun işte civataları
olsun bunları bir gözden geçirip daha
sonra yola çıkmayı tercih ediyorum
ikinci bir zorluk sa Kendinizi çok yoğun
olması gerekiyor ya kendinizi çok görür
ilk günlerde bütün enerjinizi
harcarsanız devamında da hiçbir şey
olmayabilirsiniz bizi ve
seyahatlerinizde Otomobil tercih ettim
de çok büyük fayda var çünkü otomobiller
size var masini son noktaya kadar
götürmektedir lere yazmayı
bulamıyorsanız demiryolu ve havayolu
tercih etmenizde fayda var arkadaşlar
demiryolunda engelliler için bir bilim
bulunmakta keza havalimanında engelliler
için birbirini bulunmakta siz
demiryollar ve yatta Evet şu anda
Vardığımızda
bu birimlerde çalışan arkadaşlar
karşılayıp koltuk numaranızın bulunduğu
yere kadar sizi götürüyorlar kadar
inişte de tekrar sizi karşılıyorlar bu
noktada yani çok büyük bir faydaları
oluyor gelelim ben bu ulaşım
yöntemlerini kullanarak Nereye gittim
neleri gördüm ve çektiği fotoğraflarla
Size bunları ver akraba istiyorum
Fethiye Babadağ yamaç paraşütü yaptım
Yavaş konuştuğunu katlandığı iki tane
Pis var bu iki piste de minibüslerle
çıkabiliyor olacak arkadaşlara yardımcı
oluyorlar Bence Burada yavaş başka
yapmak için hiçbir engel bulunmuyor ve
fotoğraflarda hemen göstereyim
Nemrut Dağı'na çıktım nemrut'ta giderken
Elazığ Havaalanı kullandım Elazığ
üzerinden oradan Adıyaman Adıyaman'da
Nemrut Nemrut Dağı'na var bu sonra bir
kısım da rampa var Orhan Dayı yürümek
zorlanabilirsiniz ve yıldız arkadaşınız
varsa onun yardımıyla Nemrut Dağı'na
çıkabilirsiniz
o ankara-izmir tren de gidebilirsiniz
tren Galata'da bulunan engelli
masalarından yardım alabilirsiniz
İzmir'e vardığınızda İzmir'de Metro
bulunduğu Metro kullanabilirsiniz
İzmir'de kurduğunda geçebilirsiniz Eğer
beni bu yüzmeyi seviyorsanız İzmir'in
ilçelerinde de üstüne girebilir mi
ve yine kendi aracınızda hayatınızı
tenisiyle gelirsiniz içki ilçesinde bir
çok iyi gecebilirsiniz Eskişehir'de
Tamam ay bulunmakta
Eskişehir Tamam haydi her tarafını
gezebilirsiniz Eğer içerde gitmek
isterseniz çok ilginç bir Ülkesi var
Hangisi hangi ilçesinde yer altı
şehirlerine görebilirsiniz
o
Çanakkale girebilirsiniz Çanakkale her
ne kadar düzgün yer olsa da ulaşmasından
bazı zorlukları bulunuyor kendi
aracınızla a etmez tavsiye ederim
Çanakkale'ye gitti de Şehit fil
görebilirsiniz
o Kapadokya girebilirsiniz Kapadokya'da
balonlar bilmenizde hiçbir bu
sebepler gerçekten balığımızı gitti
gerçekten sizler için güvenli Ben
demedim
ha Türkiye'de giderek en güzel yerlerden
biri İstanbul İstanbul'a Ankara hızlı
tren de gidebilirsiniz
devamında İstanbul'da çeşitli düşünenler
var bunların hepsini kullanabilirsiniz
vapura binerken inerken biraz dikkat
etmeniz lazım O kısımlarda engellilerle
ilgili bazı Doktorlar düşünmemiş
Müzesi'ni gezebilirsiniz üzere çok güzel
ve içerisini engellilere göre
tasarlanmış Tamam Engelle gördük
sağlanmıştır verim onlar da güzel vakit
içerisinde bu
ve
yurt dışına çıkabilirsiniz yok Sen
çıkmadan önce pasaportunuz almamız
gerekiyor pasaport işlemlerini
tamamladıktan sonra havaalanına
gittiğinizde yardım adasındaki
arkadaşlar size yardımcı oluyorum Şu ana
kadar götürüyorlar indiriyor
karşılıyorlar
pasaport kontrolü kısmından diğer plan
geçebilirsiniz yardım masasını
desteğiyle yurtdışında birçok yeri
gezebilirsiniz yurt dışında Eğer yapan
temiz varsa hiçbir problem çekmezsiniz
ise
metrosundan faydalanabilirsiniz
sistemlerinden faydalanabilirsiniz
Londra
Au beni ya
ama Barcelona
suyu
Amsterdam al
Budapeşte
merakını çözerim sayesinde birçok ülke
ve şehir gördüm yeni kültürlerle
tanışmak dünyayı daha iyi anlamama
yardımcı oldu sizlere tavsiyem sırt
çantanızı alın ve yollara koyup
da o
[Müzik]
abone ol
[Alkış]